make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay here's the thing
here is the thing here dude here is the
thing okay
so Donnie Cates riding Thor or right
right it kind of threw me off right
because reading venom like the way he
handles venom is really really good
here's here's here's something you guys
need to understand
Donnie case is writing both four and
venom this is a perfect indication of
how art can totally change the tone of a
comic because if Ryan's segment for
example had been drawing this comic I
feel like I might have taken away from
things but like when you when you look
at this for what it is like when you go
through and you look at the comic itself
and you've got like Nick Kline who's the
one that's drawing it totally changes
the tone in the comic and this is
absolutely amazing do Donnie Cates do
this issue number one is nuts right as
it's absolutely awesome so here's the
thing this comes off the heels not
really directly off the heels of of war
of realms in reality it doesn't even
come off the heels of King Thor it takes
place probably a little while after war
of realms we're not really given like a
definitive time frame we're told like
it's been a while since the war of
realms happened basically but it's
basically kicks off with like the hammer
of Thor just like traveling through
space right just like literally
traveling through all of the realms so
the first thing that goes through the
realm of the Vanier Alfheim it goes
through like the realm of Nadav Alire it
goes through like Jotunheim it goes
through all of the ten realms and this
is one this is like one of the coolest
coolest openings to a thor comic ever
right because like Thor's voice is
basically emanating from this hammer to
all these realms and presumably it's
just kind of an echo of his voices left
behind like as he speaks like once it
passes through that realm everybody in
that area can hear it but it's one of
the coolest things because what he
basically says is it's been a while
since we had the war of realms and with
that conflict we did enough fighting to
last millennia and so what he basically
says is at this point now the old king
is dead right Odin's dead and out of the
picture I am now the king of Asgard let
there be peace or let there be thunder
ie cooler britches or I'm coming down
there and all hell is gonna break loose
and it's an awesome way to do this right
because the hammer actually ends up
traveling to Midgard right travels
through earth it basically smashes
through the head of a monster that I am
an and Captain America and the Avengers
are fighting and just lands on the
ground and then Iron Man's law does
anybody have a sharpie so it's kind of a
cool thing cuz at that point it switches
back over to Thor who looks kind of
awesome
by the way like as a sort of Odin s
character that's that's one of the funny
things that goes on is because in every
indication every depiction of Thor in
the future when he looks
like basically when he takes over he
looks like Odin in a lot of different
ways right so I guess kind of makes
sense he's his biological son but still
like it looks pretty awesome because
he's talking to SIF and he's like what
do you think about that and sips like
yeah you know it's kind of cool
the other cool thing here is that SIF
has taken over the role of Heimdall and
and essentially she sees everything now
right so like she's the new Heimdall and
it's cool to see this right like the
fact that they kind of have a role for
her cuz if we're being honest with
ourselves when it comes to lady SIF one
of the biggest problems for character
has had is after the run of Walt
Simonson really if you kind of look at
it for what it is after the run of Walt
Simonson model didn't really know what
to do with her a lot of people didn't
like you go from what Simonson's run
which is the the last big significant
run before you got in a danger guns run
in the mid to late 1990 90s and you kind
of get this this like okay lady Sif's
just there and like she's a chick that
Thor is hooking up with from time to
time and that's basically it now you
start to get into like the mid-2000s and
you get into like the relaunch journey
and a mystery stories and she gets
really really awesome especially when
you get into J michael Straczynski run
on for didn't she gets really really
cool but there was a period of time when
she was just kind of like the chick who
was there and more recently that sort of
been the case right like this with this
girl who's kind of been there with floor
and they slept together they've been in
a relationship then Thor broke up with
her and they ended up you know give him
the Jane Foster then that ended then he
was back with SIF again and it's one of
these things were kind of on-again
off-again but it's cool that Marvel's
would have given her a role in the
services she's like the new Heimdall the
other part of this is the reason why I
why Iron Man asked for a sharpie is
because he wrote on the hammer nice shot
enjoy your retirement which is a cool
little message to Thor is a cool little
thing but the funny thing about this is
that Thor does not like being King I
wouldn't really say he hates being King
but it's certainly something that he's
not used to but it's not something that
he's really prepared for because it
requires a whole different kind of skill
set and this was really brought to bear
when he basically dismisses Volks
Volstagg who's asking about like the
alcohol they're supposed to have for
like some big a big dinner and like the
food and so on and so forth and Thor's
like I had better things to worry about
than that and Loki shows up now of
course Loki's leading the frost giants
right that came out of Jason Aaron's run
on Thor that Loki's basically in charge
of the frost giants after the war of
realms and all that but one of the
things he does and this is a really
really important conversation as he
starts talking to Thor he starts he
starts asking questions what's it like
are you used to it that kind of a thing
and this is important because what it
does is it establishes if Thor's out of
his element here Thor's never been never
really been a king of Asgard up to this
point there have been times where he
stood in place of Odin right like when
Odin died after the events of of Dan
Jergens run when he died against Serdar
then like Thor took over his leader
right um he was a short-lived leadership
he ended up dying shortly after during
Ragnarok but like there's been times
where he's been like an interim king but
Odin always ends up coming back and the
indication here is that there is no Odin
here right now right like Thor is the
tried and true king of Asgard now and
because of that you know it kind of
makes sense given the fact that Odin in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is now
gone and as we know and at this point
the comics really kind of copied the
movies as opposed to the other way
around and so what you get is basically
Thor completely taking over the role and
it's awesome because Loki starts hitting
at that and he's like he's like are you
sure you're ready for something like
this right like and and that's that's
the case like Thor has led soldiers in a
battle he's he's fought all manner of
different enemies but being a king
requires a whole new type of skill
because not every problem as king can be
solved with just like conquering your
enemy as a key you have to know
diplomacy but you have to understand
that sometimes the pen is mightier than
the sword right that sometimes you have
to go to your enemy and you have to find
a diplomatic way in order to avoid
warfare right Thor's not really used to
that the words just like used to going
in with his hammer and just like smiting
everything within sight and so it's a
strange situation for him not only that
where he goes to get up Loki basically
says where he asks him it's getting
heavier isn't it of course making
reference to Mjolnir and that's when we
start to learn that this is true that
apparently what's happening is that for
Thor the the hammer of milner is getting
heavier now what it seems to indicate is
Thor is becoming less worthy now it
doesn't mean that Thor is losing his
power or losing his worthiness innocent
in its entirety right so before you guys
who you know couple the bandwagon and
Thor is losing his word you know that
doesn't really seem to be the case in
reality it's too early to know if that's
that's really what's happening on now if
you had the ability to see the future
and you know this is what nany Cates is
gonna do then let me know right because
I could use those winning lottery
numbers but assuming that you can't
basically we don't know exactly what's
gonna go on here it could be that the
enchantment of Odin is actually wearing
off and so Thor may be coming unworthy
to a degree but it's only because of the
fact that the enchantment that Odin put
on there is changing or whatever the
case is we also still don't really know
how Donna Cates is tying into the story
of Jason Aaron insofar as the hammer is
sentient right so it could be that Thor
is not really becoming unworthy the
hammer just wants to be wielded by
somebody else we don't know
there's too many there's too much
ambiguity here we don't really have the
answer so if we really just kind of have
to ride this out the other part is that
Thor is getting ready to make his first
speech to Asgard as king and it makes
him nervous and this is cool because the
idea of seeing Thor uncertain and unsure
of himself is something that you don't
really see all that often
my Thor is usually depicted in Marvel
Comics as the guy who just kind of got
it all figured out in the sense that he
knows exactly what he's supposed to do
he knows exactly how things are supposed
to pop off and that's basically it
now again a lot of that ties into the
fact that Thor is only real history when
it comes to Marvel it's fighting
alongside the Avengers or alongside the
Warriors 3 or you know in any number of
superhero ensemble groups or sometimes
by himself and just pummeling an enemy
with a hammer and so getting out in
front of everybody in Asgard and saying
okay so like here's what's up people
making it a State of the Union so to
speak it's something that that really
kind of throws him off the issue with
this is he never actually makes a speech
and the reason why is because Galactus
comes crashing down into Asgard
dude it's nuts dude this is this is
crazy as soon as this happened I was
just like what in the heck man
Donny Cates man what in the heck Donny
case doesn't just dismiss this like
Galactus crashes and then like a little
while later Thor immediately goes to
attack now understand there's history
here and that's one of the great things
about what Donna Cates is doing is he's
not wiping the slate clean those of you
guys who remember who who were read
throughout the history of Thor but there
was a great big huge battle that took
place when Galactus showed up on on a
toss guard trying to take the Galactus
sea right like the sea that would give
birth to a new universe he wanted to
remove a mass guard and to consume it
but the issue with this is that Thor
really is and with that history kind of
being there between the two of them
Thor's first in first instance is to
attack Galactus because his thought is
Galactus has come to Asgard to attack it
because Odin is not there anymore it
makes sense the Thor would react the way
that he does but immediately Galactus
says stop I'm not here to attack you I'm
not here to conquer you I'm here because
basically like you're the only one who
can basically can really help me out
here that the star plague is on its way
here the great black winner and it's a
cool thing because when that happens
like literally what we end up learning
is that following this and everything
that's coming that basically the world
tree of a drasil begins to die and so
what Thor does is he calls together all
of the heralds of Galactus now this is
the smartest move the Thor could make
and the reason why is because given the
nature of the Herald's and so far as as
characters like alpha ray characters
like Stardust the Silver Surfer frankerq
a cosmic Ghost Rider prey toward but
basically with all these different
heralds they've all sir
under the direction of Galactus at
different points in time and they've all
experienced different things and so
literally the question of a four is what
is the black winter like one of you guys
has to know and none of them really
gives an answer at least not until a
Silver Surfer shows up uh what he
basically says is like this black winter
is essentially the end of all things
right is referred to in a bunch of
different names the flight storm the
rock blizzard it's the one true end
right the definitive end to all things
and it's kind of this funny scenario
right because we'll talk more about what
that means here in a second but what
Silver Surfer says is that Galactus has
faced the black winter twice the first
time he faced the black winter was when
he was Galan and then became you know
basically died with the six iteration of
the universe and then became Galactus
and in the next version the second time
after that was what basically just
happened Galactus showing up missing an
arm and landing in Asgard and so because
that what the Silver Surfer says is
there are five planets out there that
exists in the universe that he's kept
hidden from Galactus and the reason why
is because those five particular planets
if one of them or in or all of them were
consumed by Galactus it would give him
an insane amount of power a more
powerful version of Galactus than what
we've ever seen before if he ever were
to get a hold of any of these planets
and it's kind of a crazy thing because
what the Silver Surfer says is the
lactis was never meant to know about
these worlds right he was never meant to
be able to consume them because nobody
really knew what would happen if
Galactus achieved that higher level of
power the assumption is the more
powerful Galactus became the more he
would need to consume and so what this
would mean is that if he consumed this
in any one of these worlds his power
would be amplified and he would have to
consume other worlds at a much faster
rate in order to keep that power
satisfied right because it'd be like an
addiction to him of sorts this need to
kind of keep this power going to keep
him at his current level and so what
silver.silver says is that because of
what's coming that they have to go and
consume you know either one or all five
of these worlds they have to consume all
of them in order to basically keep the
star plague from consuming and
destroying presumably everything in
existence and so what is up happening is
is you get this really really cool
moment where basically for leads you
know these these warriors and meets the
the heralds to basically find these
worlds and at least to bring the lactis
to them and when the question is asked
like are you ready for this Galactus
says no like that's not going to happen
and the reason why and it gets kind of
wild here the reason why is because when
he says like when Galactus talks about
the star plate what he says is that when
you look at it you see your absolute
death right in the same way that
everybody who looks at Galactus every
race who looks at Galactus sees Galactus
as a version of their own race right so
if you were human you see
Galactus is human if you're a scroll you
see him as a scroll and so on and so
forth that when it comes to the star
plague when it comes to this black
winter when you look upon it you see
your definitive death you see how it is
that you are going to die what Donnie
Cate seems to be doing here we don't
really know we won't know until we get
you know find out what the the star
plague is but what Donnie Cate seems to
be doing here is changing Marvel history
changing the true reason for why it is
that Galan became the likeness of the
first place now the reason why I say
that is if you go back and you read
Adventures of the x-men issue number 12
what you learn is a being called the
dweller in darkness and the dweller in
darkness was this guy who wanted to
essentially consume the entirety of the
of the multiverse into himself so that
when the multiverse was created anew
that he would be born with this
astronomical level of how ultimately he
was defeated but he had fractured the
m'kraan crystal and when that happened
what it did is it led to the destruction
of that universe and ultimately the
universe that Galactus was in when he
was a space explorer Galan and so when
the universe was reborn again Galan was
born into this new universe as Galactus
what seems to be going on here is Ani
cases either taking that concept of the
dweller in darkness and blending it in
and modifying a little bit or he's
completely wiping the weller dweller and
darkness out of existence that entire
origin is being completely wrecked on
and changed entirely
and then we won't really know what comes
next but what what Galactus says here is
that when he looked at the at the the
black winter the the definitive death he
saw for himself
was Thor he basically saw that Thor was
going to kill him and so when that
happens Galactus immediately starts
blasting for and what he says is if this
is going to happen but if this is going
to happen I did not come here to be your
ally I did not come here to be your
friend I came here for that for this one
simple purpose that if you are going to
be the reason why I die then you and I
are gonna go face this black winter
together you and I are going to destroy
the black winter together so that when
the time comes when you do become my
death I'll have you close and then we'll
see how that battle fares out and he
says until then rise the herald of
thunder Galactus makes Thor into his
Herald well that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb cork if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I'll catch you all later peace
we've got some new patrons in our top
tiers over on patreon.com slash comments
explained I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Austin H Phillip and
Austin B as well as Steven Z Eagle F
Joey M and Jeff are as well as Genesis
916 as always we just usually keep the
last name - an initial it helps you guys
to maintain your anonymity some of you
guys are expressed concerned about
having like your first and last name
thrown out there for the world to see I
do not blame you for you guys who have
joined up as part of our patreon tiers
that are eligible for Rob Court honor
guard rings those whose rings have been
sent out you should already have them if
you're a new person who just joined up
and you've been part of this - here for
a month your ring will be mailed out to
you so I want to say thank you guys for
being patrons
[Music]
[Music]